[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to the first Data
Science Hangout of 2023.
I hope you're all
having a great week.
But if we haven't had
a chance to meet yet,
thanks for joining us.
I'm Rachael.
It's nice to meet you.
This is an open space for the
whole data science community
to connect and chat about data
science leadership, questions
you're facing, and getting
to learn about what's
going on in the world of data
across different industries.
And so each week, we feature a
different data science leader
as my co-host to help
lead the discussion
and answer any
questions from you all.
So together, we're all
dedicated to making
this a welcoming
environment for everybody,
so I love when we can hear from
everyone no matter your level
of experience or area of work.
And if you've been here before,
you've heard this spiel a lot.
But there's always three ways
you can ask questions but also
provide your perspective.
So you can jump in by raising
your hand here on Zoom.
You can put questions
into the Zoom chat.
And feel free to just put
a little star next to it
if you wanted me to read it
from the Zoom chat instead.
Otherwise, I could call on you
to introduce yourself and add
some context.
But we also have a Slido link
where you can ask questions
anonymously.
And so I see Tyler and Hannah.
Thank you.
Both just shared
that in the chat.
But we share the
recordings of each session
up to the Posit YouTube,
so you can always
go back and find
helpful resources
and see an overview
of each week.
And we also have a LinkedIn
group for the Hangout,
too, which I'll share in the
chat here in just a second.
One other note I wanted to
add here in the beginning
too is, if anybody is
hiring right now and wants
to share that in the chat, feel
free to put the link to the job
descriptions there.
I was going to
share a link in a--
little bit later
for Chase Carpenter,
who was one of our featured
leaders from the Chicago Cubs.
They're hiring an assistant
director of database marketing.
But for our first
Hangout of 2023,
I am very excited to have
Justin Elszasz here joining us.
Justin is Chief Data Officer
for the city of Baltimore.
And Justin, I'd love to
have you introduce yourself
and probably fix
where I messed up
on pronouncing your last
name, and share a little bit
about your role,
and maybe something
you like to do in
your free time, too.
Sure, cool.
Thanks for the invite, Rachael.
Yeah, I know we originally
planned on November,
so I didn't intend--
or I don't know if I deserve to
be the first of the new year,
but here we are.
Yeah, so my name
is Justin Elszasz.
You pronounced it fine.
Just pretend the
Zs aren't there.
I've been-- so my role
is Chief Data Officer
for the City of Baltimore.
I've been with the City for
a little over five years now.
I started off as
the data scientist
for our innovation team.
So about five years ago,
we were given a grant
from Bloomberg
Philanthropies to create
one of their innovation teams.
I think there's about 25 or 30
cities with these innovation
team grants now.
So from there, I spent about,
I want to say, two years
in that role.
We then merged our
innovation team with our--
with CitiStat, our
performance management team
and added a third program,
our Data Fellows program,
and I became the deputy
director for what
we call the Office of
Performance and Innovation.
I spent about a year
and a half in that role,
and up until then, our
chief data officer position
had been in our IT agency.
So Baltimore City
Information Technology
reporting to our CIO.
About two years ago when we
got a new administration--
Mayor Brandon Scott
came in, we also
added a new position called
the City Administrator, which
is kind of like a chief
operating officer for the city.
The decision was made to move
the chief data officer role out
of our IT agency and to report
to our city administrator.
So it definitely kind of
raised the profile of data
within the administration,
provided executive leadership
support around data and how
to use it more strategically.
And so when the role was moved
over to the mayor's office,
that's when I took the role.
So yeah, coming up on-- coming
up on two years in that role.
That's just incredible.
So over the last two years,
part of the rationale
for moving it into
the mayor's office
was to put a little bit more
emphasis obviously on strategy
and how to use data and
analytics quite a bit
more strategically than we had
been, but also data governance.
So we recognized data quality
continues to be an issue.
There are constantly questions--
and this is true of any city
government or any
jurisdiction, really--
around when you can
and can't share data,
what are the best uses, what
uses should we not pursue
of data?
So data governance is also kind
of one of those large buckets
that I'm responsible for.
So that's a little bit
about me and the role
here in city government.
We just a few
months ago announced
we'd be using ARPA funding.
So ARPA is American
Rescue Plan Act.
This is federal funding
in response to COVID.
Baltimore received about
$640 million in ARPA funding,
and we're using 2
million of that to create
a digital services team.
So that will be in my office.
We've been recruiting.
Our director of
digital services,
the city's first director
of digital services,
just started on Monday.
Their name is Shelby Switzer.
They came from the Beck Center
and from US Digital Services.
So really excited to
have them on board.
I posted a link in the chat.
We are still hiring
for a couple of roles--
lead developer and lead
UX designer in particular.
So if you or--
if you're interested or know
folks, please reach out, apply.
And I can also talk a
little bit about maybe
some anticipated new
roles later this year
that would be in my office.
Fingers crossed.
But we can get to
that as it comes up.
So yeah, that's kind
of a quick intro.
Happy to take questions, or--
yeah, however however
you all want to roll.
Yeah, awesome.
And what about something you
like to do in your free time,
too?
Ha ha, free time.
I've got two--
I've got two kids.
One is going to be
five on Saturday,
and the other one's two
and 1/2, and he's just
leaning really hard into
that terrible two mode.
Just really growing into it.
So it's-- pandemic has
been fun for raising kids.
A lot of fun.
It's been a lot [INAUDIBLE].
So that's mostly my free time.
I read a, lot and I'm into
road cycling quite a bit.
But it's mostly the
kids these days.
That's great.
Happy birthday to them.
While we're waiting
for some questions
to come in from
everybody, it sounds
like there's a lot of change
across the organization
and a lot of new data roles.
And I was curious
how you're going
about building data literacy
through city government?
Yeah, that's a great question.
It has grown by
leaps and bounds,
even just in the five
years since I've been here.
There were a few
things that I've been
kind of either pursuing or--
but there's-- and
then more generally,
how it's kind of
gone for the city.
So similar to this
group, Rachael,
one of the first
things I did when
I came into city government was
kind of stealing from my old--
my previous job was--
so I came into the mayor's
office as a data scientist,
but I didn't know who
were all the data people
and all the different agencies.
So created the-- called it the
Data Center for Excellence,
which was basically
just a once a month--
basically a Hangout.
Someone might present
some of the work
that they're involved
in, or maybe a new tool
they're trying out,
issues they're having.
So that was one of the first
communities of practice
we kind of established around
data and city government,
and that was meant
to, again, kind
of connect the data people.
There are a couple of things--
so that was a few years ago.
There have been a
few other-- like,
we have a Women
in Data group now
forming a community of practice
and a safe space for women
and minorities in
the data-- in data.
Most recently though, it's been
more of a concerted effort,
especially as I've taken on
the role of Chief Data Officer.
There are a couple of places.
One is launching a data academy.
So we have been piloting it
maybe for the last two months
with the Center for
Government Excellence.
This is another
Bloomberg-funded group,
but they're at Johns
Hopkins, literally right
around the corner from me.
And yeah, so we've been
developing a curriculum for--
for the Data Academy.
Where we've chosen to focus is--
it'd be very easy
to start creating
some kind of curriculum that's
for data analysts and data
scientists, right?
Like, here are the tools
we use in city government,
here's intermediate
to advanced Power BI,
or whatever the case might be.
But instead, what
we chose to focus
was on folks with little
or no data literacy.
So think about your frontline
workers, your solid waste
collection crews, your housing
inspector, those folks.
And so we've named a
few different tracks
within the academy
that we're working on,
but the first one that we've
really given a lot of focus
is this kind of
foundations of data--
data literacy, which is really
just about what our data-- how
does it show up in your life?
How does it show
up in your work?
So trying to start at the
very foundational level
so we can make sure we're
bringing everyone along
in growing data literacy.
Another area that's-- and
so we're actually right
in the middle of trying to
consolidate a lot of these
disparate efforts around
data literacy into a more
comprehensive
workforce strategy.
Another component is around
our job classifications.
So in government there's always
your job your functional job
title might be data scientist,
but for us, we still
have actual classifications
that are more like operations
manager or operations officer.
We are working with
our IT department
to modernize a lot of tech and
data related classifications
so that we can then
work with our agencies
so that they know better what
they're actually looking for.
I know it's similar in
the industry where, if--
if the organization
is relatively
new to data
scientists, they think
they need a data scientist
first and so they
hire a data scientist.
But that person might
quickly get burnt out
because what they really
end up doing is entirely
data cleaning or creating
a better data collection
tool in the first place,
which was kind of my--
if I'm honest, that
was what my role was
like when I initially came in.
So getting agencies
to see that there's
a whole universe of data roles,
and trying to fit the best--
the best one to their needs.
So that's another area
where there's a lot about--
a lot of talk and a lot of
work going into growing data
literacy within government.
Thank you.
I see a lot of chat
going on back and forth,
and great resources
being shared, too.
Katherine.
I know you had a question
earlier in the chat.
Do you want to jump in?
KATHERINE GERTON: Hey.
I was just bringing up--
said you were working
with the people
at Johns Hopkins, that at
the last RStudio conference,
that organization Data
Trail that presented
kind of focusing on
many of the things
that you were speaking to.
Different job
classifications and things
like that, not focused
within government,
but just that it is really kind
of an industry-wide problem
going from their
focus for interns
all the way up
through any position.
So I was just sharing
that with you,
and I think somebody else
included the link to the talk
that there's really
a lot of opportunity
there for partnership, but
even in your own neighborhood.
JUSTIN ELSZASZ: Yeah, it's
funny you mention them.
So I haven't talked
to Jeff in a while.
So Jeff and I actually met--
gosh, this would have been
maybe three or so years ago.
I don't think it had been called
the Data Trail at the time,
but it was a similar--
I think it might have been
the same or a similar program.
They were looking to train--
KATHERINE GERTON: Yeah, I think
they went through a rebrand.
JUSTIN ELSZASZ: Yeah, yeah.
Training-- yeah, really high
school and college students
from East Baltimore
in data science.
We actually did hire
one on for an intern--
I think it might have
been an internship
about three years ago.
Yeah, it's a great idea.
In fact, I think the
person we had hired
had started in on college.
They were pursuing-- they had
started pursuing a degree in--
I want to say it was music or--
music or recording,
sound recording.
Decided that wasn't
for them, wasn't sure
what was next, and found out
about this program and said,
yeah this is actually something
I'm really interested in.
And so yeah, they spent
some time with us.
And the really cool thing is he
also created a small consulting
firm.
They were called
Problem Forward.
I think they're still around.
But for those folks who don't--
who go through that program
but don't find an
immediate role elsewhere,
Problem Forward was spun up as
a small consulting firm that
would hire the people that
they've trained in that
program.
And it was a consulting
firm, so they would just
take on small projects
with local businesses.
So it was a really cool model.
Yeah, we've definitely
worked with them in the past.
I haven't recently, but yeah,
it's a great reminder that
yeah, some of--
this is obviously a national
and international community
around data science--
science.
But there's even
hyper-local networks
of data science going on, too.
Thank you.
I'm seeing a few plus ones to
Alan's question from earlier.
And Alan, I'd love
to have you jump
in next with your question.
Sure.
Hey Justin, hey everybody.
I'm really curious.
Maybe Justin, if you could sort
of blow up super high level
and talk about what's
the mission of the office
that you're in, and
how does that relate
to who your customers are?
Are those residents
of the city, are they
agencies and employees?
What does the-- what are the
things you're doing look like,
and how does that--
how does that
roll out to all of those people?
Just to give context.
And then Raha's got a
great question digging more
into detail about
real specific stuff.
And I think like her,
I've got tons of questions
about doing data at a city
level, and what that's like.
So some of that high-level
context would be great.
Thanks.
Sure, yeah.
Yeah, so maybe-- step
back and give you
a little bit of the
organizational structure.
So like I said,
I report directly
to the city administrator who
is appointed by our mayor.
So I'm in the mayor's cabinet.
There's also-- but because
the role was just moved over
less than two years
ago, it didn't
come with any other roles.
So until we've now started
hiring for the Digital Services
team, I've been an office of
one as the Chief Data Officer.
The office that I came
from, the Mayor's Office
of Performance and Innovation--
like I mentioned, they have our
performance management shop,
CitiStat.
So they're looking
at broad KPIs more
as a way of either identifying
issues or holding agencies
accountable for performance.
There's-- and then the
Data Fellows program,
which is another effort we
made a couple of years ago.
We created that program to
hire in entry level data folks
to get them in the door
to city government,
and then deploy them to
agencies that needed help.
And then our innovation team.
So-- and then of course,
there's our IT agency, BCIT.
There are-- in any given agency
there are other data analysts
working with--
who become kind of subject
matter experts in their areas,
their domains.
My role-- it's a
little bit of both.
And I'm hoping by
the end of the year
it's going to be almost
kind of like 50/50.
So right now, me personally
being responsible
for things like data
governance and capacity
building-- those are both
things that are a little bit
inward-focused.
However, with building the
digital services team--
that is about building better
customer service and better
digital experiences
for residents.
So that will have
probably a resident.
But we're not-- we're not,
like, restricted to that.
But chances are, we'll
be building things
that matter, that improve
services directly to residents.
I mentioned 50/50 because
by the end of the year,
hopefully in this
new budget year
we'll be creating a more proper
data science team in my office.
So like I mentioned,
our CitiStat team really
wrestles with more high-level
KPIs and performance
at a higher level.
I think they've always wanted
to dive more deeply into data,
but these--
a lot of the performance stuff
happens on certain cycles.
So Police Stat is a meeting
that happens every two weeks.
You can't deliver a deep
insight or create new tools
on a two-week cycle.
Same with Clean Stat, which
is about cleaning the city.
So what I proposed is
creating a small analytic shop
under my office
that, whereas data--
our digital services team
would be about improving
resident-facing
services, and this is--
part of this is just a
way of making the case
that it's cost-effective.
But the analytics
shop I'm imagining
being more about efficiency
and more internally focused.
So helping agencies find--
maybe it's detecting
fraud, maybe
it's optimizing routes for
snowplows, that kind of thing.
So we have that expertise
in a few different spots,
but because it's so
sporadic, those folks
are often pulled into just
day-to-day operations or just
the regular reporting.
And we still don't--
even though we would
like to, we just
don't have the capacity
to set aside and say,
take this problem and run
for-- run with it for a month
and come back to us and
see what you've got.
So that's what I'm
looking to build,
and hopefully we'll be hiring
for three or four roles
for that by the end of the year.
Cool.
JUSTIN ELSZASZ: Does that
answer your question?
Yeah, it does.
It gave me a good sense
for where you are.
And I think that
vision of what does
a team look like that can do
more and have sort of room
to run a little bit
sounds really exciting.
Yeah, I'm excited too
because that's what--
I mean, that's a little bit
of what I had done previously,
and so--
and that's what I always
imagined data analytics
in the city looking like.
And it definitely
does in other places,
so it's a little bit of
getting us up to speed.
Now that said, there are going
to be-- the opportunities
to do that kind of thing are
much more rare than performance
management or just
simple data analysis.
Because again, there's-- it's
finding the right combination
of high enough data quality and
an agency who their leadership
and their operations will be
able to adapt and use that kind
of analysis or tools.
Because leadership,
it's on a spectrum.
Not every agency-- not every--
not all of their
heads are ready to use
the next generation of tools to
optimize our resources better.
So yeah, they'll be--
but that said, there are
those use cases out there,
and I've got a
couple of examples
I'm happy to share that
we've worked on already.
But yeah, that's what I'm
looking forward to this year.
Cool.
Thank you.
JUSTIN ELSZASZ: Yeah.
I'm really interested in
that snowplow optimization
example [INAUDIBLE].
Other cities-- other
cities, especially places like
Rochester--
a lot of Northern cities have
wrestled with that for sure.
Baltimore is one of those cities
where we get a dusting of snow
and the whole city shuts
down because it happens
so infrequently that we don't--
we can't build up that
amount of capacity
to deal with it for the rare
times we get lots of snow.
But places like Rochester
where it's like day in
and day out for six months,
yeah, they've definitely
worked on those routes.
I see a few anonymous
questions that came through,
and I to make sure
I get to those too.
And one was, what about hardware
and cloud infrastructure?
Do you have to deal
with legacy systems?
Does the new money
allow you to upgrade?
Yeah, good question.
Yes, about legacy systems.
This year, our IT
department-- so there's--
I have a little bit-- so chief
data officer roles kind of run
the spectrum in terms
of responsibilities
and where they
are, where they're
situated organizationally.
I have a little bit less
control over architecture.
That said, yes, there are
tons of legacy applications
and infrastructure to deal with.
This year, we're
targeting finally
decommissioning our mainframe,
which right now still runs
some of our
environmental citations
and some of our
revenue collections
and that kind of thing.
So we're looking
to replace that.
There's also a legacy system
with our housing department
that was home-grown
by one person
that Housing
Department had hired
who was there for 20 years.
Wasn't well-documented.
They of course
left, and now we're
kind of picking up the
scraps on that system.
And it does all of
our code enforcement
and a whole host
of other Housing--
Housing Department functions.
So yeah, legacy systems
continue to be a challenge.
Luckily we have an IT department
that's kind of on it right now
and has plans to-- to
mitigate a lot of that.
And so as those
things get replaced,
we only have up to go in
terms of data quality.
We just, over the
last two years,
have rolled out Workday
as our new ERP--
enterprise resource
planning system.
That in and of
itself I think has
addressed a lot of finance
and HR data quality issues.
So yeah, we're making
moves in that direction.
Yes, there's legacy systems.
But I challenge you all
to find a chief data
officer in another
city who doesn't
reckon with that sometimes.
And as far as cloud
goes, yeah, we--
so for one, our GIS
team is working hard
on moving out a lot
of our GIS layers
and infrastructure
over to cloud.
Of course it's with Esri,
as is our Open Baltimore,
our open data platform.
We're-- I think it's --
picking your battles and where
you're going to get the most
bang for the buck at the moment
for us.
I'm looking to pilot a couple
of tools to move to cloud.
So one that I'll mention is
we, over the summer, partnered
with a group at Carnegie
Mellon called the Data
Science for Social Good.
You may know this
already, but Baltimore
has a lot of vacant buildings.
And when a building sits
vacant for long enough,
rooftops tend to
become an issue.
And back in January
of last year,
we had three firefighters
killed when a rooftop was in--
it was a fully-involved fire.
Rooftop collapsed on the three
firefighters and were killed.
So we're using we partnered
with Carnegie Mellon
to develop an AI tool that will
detect collapsed roofs based
on our aerial flyover imagery.
Well, every year we get
new flyover imagery,
which means every year will
want to refine and update the--
the model and get
new predictions
so we can find any new buildings
that may have rooftop issues.
But we need better--
like, we're not--
we can't run that
on someone's local machine.
So that's a good
opportunity to start
pushing the bounds of
what we can do in cloud.
So that's one that I'm--
we're looking for
a couple of places
to definitely move that way.
Thank you for that example.
And I'm seeing quite
a few questions coming
into the Zoom chat now, too.
And I think Mike, you
maybe asked first,
so I'll hand it
over to you first.
Hi there.
So this is, I guess,
a topical question
for our first
session in January.
It's goal setting season.
So how do you balance--
it's a newish
team, so how do you
balance goals about
setting up your shop
and making your infrastructure
great and easy to work with,
and the goals that are I
guess the kind of higher-up,
or your customers or your
key stakeholders-- the things
they want?
Because I'm right in the
middle of that dilemma,
and it's tricky, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
One is-- I mean, if
everything's a priority,
nothing is a priority.
But at least having
enough of a mix
that some things are--
some things are for you,
some things are for others.
I'm kind of looking
at some of my own--
like I said, so up until now,
we've been in office of one.
So it's-- in some ways, these
are like the office OKRs,
and in some ways they're like
personal OKRs because I'm just
one person.
But yeah, so in terms of
the Digital Services team
and onboarding and getting
that just stood up,
we're lucky enough that the
mayor and city administrator
needed to sign off
on that spending
because it's ARPA funding.
And so-- and not only that,
but like all aware of one,
hiring challenges right
now in the market.
But two, just hiring process
in terms of city functions.
And so-- so they
rightly recognize
that actually getting that
team stood up, hiring people
is a win.
And may not have built a
new service for a resident,
or fixed anything yet,
but that is a win.
And I think we're lucky enough
that our mayor recognizes that.
So we have kind of
executive leadership
that recognizes-- that
is willing to celebrate
some of the smaller,
more inward-focused wins.
And then, yeah,
there's a pretty--
and honestly, for some of them,
there is a pretty direct--
even though it sounds ostensibly
about internal capacity
or being inward-focused,
so there's
a pretty direct line and
theory of change from,
if we improve data literacy
by building this Data Academy
program, we will improve service
delivery to our residents.
Or if we create this
digital services team,
and even getting a handful of
new experts in technology--
in civic technology,
and we will build
better services for residents.
So now that's-- I'm
lucky enough, again,
being in the public
sector space where it's--
if you can't draw
that line, chances
are you aren't doing that
thing in the first place.
Or you're not setting that goal
in the first place, you know?
So I don't know if that helps
or answers the question,
but those are a couple initial
thoughts on it, I guess.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Awesome.
Raha, I see you had asked a
question in the chat as well.
Would you want to jump in next?
Sure.
Good timing I just ran down
to make sure my Amazon package
wasn't stolen.
Oh, I'm glad that it wasn't.
No, I got there in time.
No, so I live in Baltimore,
too, and there's definitely
a lot of issues here that
I'm concerned about that I
feel data could really address.
But part of that is
making sure that you're
able to collect the
right data, that you're
able to do analysis on it, and
that someone listens to that
and makes a decision
based off it.
So I wanted to see if you
had any examples of where
that has been done, or
where you see it heading.
Like, will 311 be better?
Will street sweeping be better?
Can you make sure
certain neighborhoods
aren't underserved?
Yeah, it's a great question.
Maybe a couple of different
scales I can offer.
So, like one about--
well, this would have been
just before the pandemic.
So I cannot believe
it's been three years.
We-- so we identified a
pretty big backlog in DPW
in terms of cleaning service
requests in the city.
This was upwards of--
I want to say there were
15 or 17,000 service
requests that was backlogged.
So these are things
that had accumulated.
It was right in the
middle of the summer.
So a couple of things happened.
One was we worked
with DPW basically
to even identify
that as an issue
and start discussing how we
were going to deal with it.
And part of that was actually--
we collected a few
parameters from them.
And this is more of like
an engineering approach,
as opposed to a data
science approach.
But we built a small
heuristic model
where you could modify
the number of crews that
were online, and some of
the distribution of where
the SRs were and that kind
of thing to try and estimate
how quickly we could
drive things down.
And so you can manipulate
how many crews you have where
in the city, and you could see
whether we might or might not
get to clearing out
the backlog and when.
Because I think we had
set a particular goal
of getting that eliminated
by a certain date.
Yeah, I can't remember
the exact timing.
So one was-- that
was-- and that was
a bit of a process of
convincing that yeah, you
can ask for their parameters and
plug it into your little model.
But all they have
to do is say, I
don't know how this
model works, or I
don't believe your model to not
want to drive their decisions.
They're not going
to listen to it.
So it was a very simplistic
model that they could--
you took them along
each step and say, OK,
if you've got this
many crews here,
that means you could complete
how many SRs that day?
The other half of that one was,
they used to divide the city up
into quadrants, and they
had hard restrictions
on how many crews they would
put in each quadrant, which
meant if a quadrant-- if a
crew called off in a quadrant,
it impacted that
quadrant but no one else.
But the issue was,
if all the SRs,
if all the demand was in
another part of the city--
or in that part of the
city, you can pull a crew
from elsewhere that had a
low workload into that area.
So it was-- they were
placing arbitrary constraints
on their deployments.
We got them basically to
eliminate that way of working,
that kind of strategy,
because we proved out
that you're exacerbating the
issue by arbitrarily placing
these constraints on your crews.
So that was a really good win.
And by the way, I
think there was a Sun
article at the time about it.
The Southeast
quadrant of the city
was getting far better
service than the rest of the--
rest of the city.
So there was a
massive equity issue.
So again, just by
some simple analysis,
and showing them and
bringing them along,
we were able to make--
convince them to make
some better decisions.
The most recent example of
getting folks to make decisions
was--
so DPW is one of those where
it's a little bit tougher to--
they're a little
bit further behind,
I would say, on their growth
curves in terms of data
literacy and using
data to make decisions.
At the other end--
RAHA DASTGHEYB: They're
losing their leadership.
JUSTIN ELSZASZ: What's that?
They're also losing
their leadership.
The head of DPW resigned.
Yeah, just a couple of days--
yeah, it was like
two days ago, right?
But do they even collect the
right data in the first place?
Is it available?
Because I know you were talking
about the cleanup crews.
I think they have 16 total,
which is nowhere near enough.
And so there's something
that they need--
I mean, you don't make
hiring decisions, obviously.
There's some gap
of how they recruit
and where they get people to
do what-- and DPW especially
with solid waste.
RAHA DASTGHEYB: But
across the board,
are people collecting
the right type of data
that allows you to do the
analysis, to make decisions?
Or do you then request them to
make-- to collect that data?
How do you do that?
A lot of the--
I mean, there's
diminishing returns, right?
Like, so 311 definitely covers
a lot of our city services.
And certainly for something
like public works,
311 is meant to be the record
of the source of truth.
And so yeah, we direct
residents to 311.
That's what we
look at internally
to determine service levels.
And now that said,
we continue to have
quality issues around 311,
like you raised, that--
for example, there's
still the concern
that something gets closed,
but the work wasn't performed.
That issue-- like it's
completely dependent on what
SR type you're looking at.
Because there's 200 service
request types, and each of them
is an entirely
different workflow,
it's a different crew, it's
different people involved.
So anyways, all that to say,
I would say on the whole,
we're collecting
the right data for--
for some of the bigger areas.
I think there are some smaller
areas where we definitely
need better data.
One that comes to mind is--
it's related to illegal dumping,
but our transfer stations
where a small hauler truck could
go and drop off their loads.
Maybe they're cleaning up
debris from a construction
site or something,
so all they do
is they've got a
pickup truck and they
run a truckload of debris.
We have really long line waits
at those drop off stations.
And we've always had the--
we've always hypothesized
that because there
are those long waits
and these guys are just
trying to make money, that
if they see a long wait,
they're going to leave and
go dump their load somewhere
they shouldn't be dumping it.
And so that exacerbates
illegal dumping issues.
The problem is we
don't have either
a digital licensing or check-in
process for the transfer
stations.
So we can't actually monitor
if you have a small hauler
license, how often are
you actually checking
into the transfer station
because if we see that you have
an active small hauler license,
but you're never checking
in to a transfer station, that
might be a signal that they're
taking their loads elsewhere.
But because we don't have any
kind of digital tools for doing
that check-in process, we aren't
able to look at that issue
all that closely.
So there are definitely
pockets where we absolutely
need better data.
And again, it's always
a matter of cities
are resource-strapped.
And like you said, there's
a spectrum of leadership,
in terms of being data-driven.
So it's finding the
areas where you've
got all of the right constraints
satisfied to do some good.
Sorry, I feel like
that was a long answer.
No, that's great.
It's really interesting
to be able to dive
deep into one of
these data problems
and see all the
different sides of it.
And I know there are quite
a few questions here.
So I want to jump
over to a few others.
But Eric, I see you had asked a
question in the chat a bit ago.
Do you want to jump in?
Sure.
It's been fascinating to
hear your stories, Justin,
and really exciting to
hear these perspectives.
So I'm just kind of
curious, as somebody
who really appreciates
the tool stack
and how we're taking
modern approaches
to data science, what
kind of modern tooling
are you trying to implement
across your workflows,
especially in the government
sector where, of course,
my collaboration is mostly
with colleagues at the FDA.
And I know they tend to have
some strict requirements
in what they're allowed
to use and whatnot.
So I'm just kind of
curious how you're
handling those approaches
for best practice
of code development or
releases within your team.
Yeah, it's a joint effort
with our IT department
because for the
ransomware attack we had--
so we had a ransomware
attack here three years ago.
And a lot of cities
have experienced these
over the last couple of years.
It really ground city
government completely to a halt.
I couldn't access my email
for more than a month.
Coming out of that, there's
been a pretty strong emphasis
not only on cybersecurity,
but even just
modernizing and
professionalizing
our IT approach.
And so our IT department has
grown by leaps and bounds
in that regard.
It's a joint effort
because this is
one of those spaces
where there's
a little bit of overlap between
IT and the technology side,
but also data analytics
and that side of things
and the data
governance around it.
So things like-- we're just now
getting into what exactly is
our code repo policy.
Internally, we have Azure.
The IT department is using
Azure DevOps now for code
and deploying.
And so getting our
data analysts onto that
and getting them to recognize
the value in bringing that
into Azure is important
because of course,
on the data side and a lot
of the civic technology side,
you also want to build
open source tools.
And that's always my
preference as well.
But a lot of folks who
either come into data science
from other areas
aren't always up
to speed on software
development best practices.
And so you do get
folks writing code,
maybe code that doesn't need to
be or doesn't belong on GitHub
and really does actually
need to stay internally.
So that's something we're
actually confronting right now,
is let's get together a
policy where we all agree,
this is a great use
case for open source.
This is where you should
make something open source.
And here are the
places where we can't
make it open source and need
to keep things internal.
So there are definitely
governance issues there.
That's kind of a live
question for us Yeah,
does that answer your question?
I can't recall.
No, that's quite
interesting to me.
And I can sympathize.
In fact, I was on a
meeting just before this
where some of my colleagues
had never heard about GitHub
in this other part of the org.
And yeah, there's
lots of education
that we even have to do
in our own organizations
about some of these toolings.
But yeah, certainly, it
sounds like you're thinking
a lot of the great ideas.
And I agree.
There definitely
is a lot of overlap
that can occur between
what you're proposing
from a development
tooling perspective
and what IT is
trying to serve up.
So having that
relationship solid upfront
is always very beneficial.
And the other really
big aspect of it
for city government or
any government, really,
is that we're an organization
of organizations.
So in some respects,
yes, we have
central IT who can support
all of the other agencies.
Up until the last couple
of years, a lot of agencies
pursued their own
IT, whether they
weren't getting good
support from central IT
or not moving quickly enough or
wanted to try their own things
or wanted to use
something different
than everyone else was using.
So there's been a
lot of-- so there's
been a federated approach,
very distributed.
And that applied to
the data folks as well.
So there's an
argument to be made
that there are things we
need to centralize and put
more constraints around.
The concern is
always, well, we don't
want to slow down an agency.
If they've got someone who knows
how to use data over there,
we want them to--
and the agency knows what
they want to do with it,
we don't want to
be a bottleneck.
And we don't want
to constrain them.
We want to get them to use
that data how they need to.
So there's a balancing act
there where we're like,
yes, we need to be a
little bit more constrained
and a little bit more
centralized with some things,
but not at the
cost of innovation,
agency responsiveness,
real world problem
solving that needs to get done.
So it is a challenge when
it's not-- in some respects,
we're one organization.
And in other respects,
we're 30 organizations.
So that definitely
complicates it.
Rory, I see you shared an
example of a citizen data
science analysis in Baltimore.
I would love to hear from you
and have you ask your question,
too.
Yeah, sure.
Hey, Justin.
I'm Rory.
I live in Baltimore.
I'm in Canton.
A while ago, I don't know if you
guys have come across this yet,
but on Reddit, there's a thread
of someone scraping the water
bill page and taking a look
at who has outstanding bills.
And in general, the
gist is that there
is, I think it's
like $330 million
in water bills that haven't been
paid-- a lot of them actually
being often business
or corporate customers.
I was curious because right
now, I work in people analytics.
And I'm working on building
out a set of active and passive
listening strategy.
And so this is what's the
top of mind for me right now,
is how are you guys collecting
the needs of the city
and deciding what projects the
data team can get involved in
and really help solve
some of those issues?
So I would assume--
I've talked to a lot
of people about this.
They've seen this
Reddit thread before.
And I'm sure it's made its way
through traditional channels
to the government, as far as
working on the water bill.
I'm sure you guys have
some exposure to it.
But what I'm curious
about is if you guys
are working on any kind
of listening strategy
to pull in from outside of
traditional channels, ways
of detecting problems that
are going on in the city.
Yeah, that's a good question.
I think every team, and I think
every office or department
or agency or whatever, has
slightly different ways
of doing that.
And once we actually
have a central analytics
team as opposed to CitiStat
or some of the other data
functions, I think--
some of the criteria that
of course come to mind
are having a
project where you've
got leadership buy-in, so that
if you dive into the problem
and come up with something,
that they're actually
going to be responsive to it
and know how to approach it.
And as far as listening
goes, like I said,
it depends on the area.
But there are a few
different conduits.
There's always going
to be that issue
that the mayor cares about.
There's always going to
be issues that the city
council cares about.
You have the Mayor's Office
of Constituent Services who
deals directly with residents on
things that are maybe not just
a straightforward 311 request,
but are maybe more lengthy
or in-depth issues.
Agencies all have their own
community liaisons and PIOs
that are out in the community
and surfacing issues.
For a data team,
yeah, I don't know
how a data team
might choose based
on all of these different inputs
and communication streams.
Yeah, like I said, leadership
in data quality is another one.
Is this an issue?
Is the problem at
hand that we have
data that might help
us address the problem,
and we just need to put
some brainpower behind it?
Or is it, well, when we
actually dig into it,
we don't have data at all or.
We don't have the right
data or good enough data.
And so now, what we actually
need is to invest in a platform
or create a new 311
service request type
or put these people in contact
with constituent services.
I don't think there's any
one cohesive strategy.
Community engagement
is just messy.
And by the way, I don't want
to speak for the administration
because that's not
always my purview.
But it's certainly
a huge aspect.
And I try to regularly
do listening tours
with the agencies
themselves-- so whether it's
talking to agency heads or
deputy director of this bureau,
or even the data analysts
themselves to surface issues.
Yeah, there's no
shortage of issues
to address or even
brainpower or good ideas.
A lot of it is, there's just
limited ability to execute.
So the real battle
is prioritizing
and trying to keep focused
on something for long enough.
Right.
And discovering the
problems probably
doesn't sound like it's a
very big issue for you guys.
You have the channels to get at
what some of the problems are.
Maybe a listing strategy that
is built out from the central
would help you see who's
complaining about it the most.
And that might help from a
prioritization perspective.
But I mean, we're still
trying to figure that out
even in private
companies who have
a little bit more
control over how
we spend our time sometimes.
So I mean, I think it's
a relatively new thing
that people are trying to talk
about and develop strategies
around.
I'm sure it'll take
you guys some time
to get there once you've
determined it's a bigger
need than it is right now.
Yeah, and I think--
Cool, thank you
for that answer.
Yeah, I also think that
the 100,000-foot level,
for Baltimore, the priority
areas are of course are public
safety and city cleanliness.
And so the issue is that
solutions to both of those
can be completely based on
neighborhood within the city.
It's very hyper-local,
both of those issues.
And so for issues like that,
your qualitative information,
the voice of the residents, is
just as important, if not more
important, to make sure you've
got a sustainable solution
to address those problems.
The data that we have
centrally to maybe analyze
some of these situations
may or may not
tell us something at
a very local level.
We may have [INAUDIBLE]
one data, yeah,
we can zoom in on
a particular block.
But for other issues, we may
not have data at that scale.
And so you've got to go
listen to the residents.
I have one quick
follow-up question, Rachel,
if you don't mind.
We have quite a few questions.
I just want to make sure I can
get to a few of those others,
too.
Is that--
Yeah, maybe I can ask
in a yes or no format.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: it's a quick
one, if it's a quick one.
I'll ask just a quick
yes or no format question
about qualitative
data collection.
I'm sort of like, text analysis
is also an interest of mine
that I follow.
And I was just
curious if you guys
are looking into that, if
implementation of deep learning
models is something
that is a big security
conversation for you guys.
You can answer it
yes or no if you'd
like, just to help move on.
Yes.
OK, cool, I figured as much.
I can say more.
And by the way, we haven't
gotten into AI ethics.
But AI ethics is
something we're going
to start working on here
in the city as well.
Cool.
I'll follow up with
you on the side maybe
to get you chatting
more about Baltimore.
And I don't know who the other
person was from Baltimore.
But maybe they'll
want to loop in, too.
Yeah.
RORY O'GALLAGER: Thank you.
Appreciate it.
It was Raha in the chat, too.
RORY O'GALLAGER:
Raha, cool, thank you.
Well, Justin, I
forgot to ask you.
Do you have a hard stop
at the top of the hour?
Do you have a few
minutes to go over, or?
I don't even remember.
I love this conversation.
I just-- I didn't want
to cut things off.
I'm good.
I don't have a hard stop.
OK, Timothy, I saw you had
a great question on getting
buy-in and leading to change.
Would you want to jump in?
Hello, yeah.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: There you are.
Yeah, thanks.
Thank you for hosting, again.
And it's a really
interesting talk.
I'm always trying
to translate things
that people bring
in to what we're
doing at my research institute.
And yeah, my question
was sort of around,
what are some key
lessons that you had?
Because you're trying
to do, it sounds
like, a lot of change,
a lot of scary changes
to a lot of people.
And resources are limited
pretty much everywhere,
but specifically in
the public sector.
And I'm in academic research.
So I was wondering, how do you--
what are some key
lessons as to how
to navigate that sort of change
leadership part of things?
Yeah, oh my god,
how long do we have?
You have three--
you have 300 words.
Oh man, yeah, one
thing I've learned,
and I think this was probably
a mistake of mine early
on in the CDO
role, was there's--
so when it comes
to data governance,
there's a variety of different
issues you could be tackling.
There's different approaches.
What I had convinced
myself of was the need for,
let's stand up this broad
data governance committee
for the city.
Every agency will
have a representative.
We're going to take one
issue area at a time.
But everyone, every agency,
every representative
needs to make some
progress on that area.
So if it's data quality, we
created this data quality
guidebook or toolkit.
And so step by step,
the idea was that month
after month, every
day [INAUDIBLE],,
but make some kind of progress.
Sorry, did I freeze?
Can you guys hear me?
Yeah, a little bit.
But [INAUDIBLE].
I thought it was on my end.
I was just checking my Wi-Fi.
OK, I think that was probably
the wrong approach, especially
in an environment of
such limited bandwidth,
not only from the agency side,
but from my own bandwidth.
I think I'm having a lot
more success in doubling down
on the areas where
there is obvious buy-in,
and people want to
change something.
Trying to get everyone to move
an inch in the same direction
was a real grind.
And I'm not convinced it has
the same impact as finding
the one or two people who
want to go a couple of miles
with you.
So I think that's been one
of my big lessons learned
over the last two years.
And maybe that's
only when you're
so resource-constrained
as to be an office of one.
But yeah, I think that's one
of my main lessons learned
on that front.
Of course, all of the other
typical change management
advice applies, right, like
listening and making sure
you're actually solving someone
else's problem and not just
your problem or what you
perceive as being the problem.
But yeah, I don't know.
Does that help?
Yeah, definitely.
I definitely want to leave
time for more questions.
But I think I'm seeing
some repeating themes.
One is like, it seems like
feudalism is still alive
and well, even in
the 21st century.
And that's something
to navigate.
But also the point
that you raise,
which is if you don't
necessarily have the authority
to just tell people what to do,
especially in other agencies,
then I think it's good to
find people who are already
willing to go with you.
And then build your
success stories.
And then say, hey, we did this.
And this indicator
went up for whatever
the good direction was.
We saw a massive
improvement with this person
who was willing to
go the extra mile
or do a little bit
of a side project
and then build that as a success
story for others, I guess.
Yeah, even when you
are the person that
has the authority to say,
yeah, you have to do this--
look, I report to the
city administrator,
who, like I said, is kind of
the chief operating officer.
They early on were more
involved in setting
some of the expectations
around data governance.
But agencies are under
countless, countless unfunded
mandates that, the mayor
wants him to do this.
These are the
things that they're
legally obligated to do.
They've got citizens
wanting them
to go in this
direction, all of whom
have a right to
claim that they have
a voice in what that
agency is doing.
And I'm just one
of those voices.
So yeah, I report to
the city administrator.
I'm the chief data officer.
That comes with some authority.
But that still doesn't mean
the thing is going to get done.
And not only that.
If I take the approach of,
well, I'm in the mayor's office,
so you have to listen to
me, it's going to backfire.
And people aren't going
to want to work with me.
So that card is best kept
for as long as possible
in your back pocket because it
just burns bridges so quickly.
So yeah, the idea
is really, no matter
what, to find a way to ensure
folks that what they're doing
is in their best
interest genuinely,
not just selling
them on something.
Yeah, yeah, it's
definitely tough.
But yeah, I appreciate it.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you so much, Justin.
And I know we're at
the top of the hour.
And a bunch of people might have
to drop to other meetings, too.
But I did want to just
ask one more question.
And I can't remember
who asked it.
It was maybe Sepp or Alan,
was asking about cross-city
collaboration between different
data teams, and if there's--
I'm not remembering
exactly the question,
but if there's a way to connect
with other city governments
and work together?
And I think I've seen this a lot
in the pharma space recently,
in all these big pharma
companies working together
and creating packages--
curious if there's something
that exists in government.
Yes, I often tell folks
that's one of the best
parts of working
in government, is
we don't have to worry
about protected information
or competition.
And so there are a few
different networks.
A couple that we purchased--
so Bloomberg Philanthropies is
pretty big in the
local government space.
So Michael Bloomberg's
theory of change
was that, if you really
want to make an impact
and impact people's lives,
local government is the place
to be because at the
federal level, yeah,
you've got very
wide, broad impact.
But it is very hard to
see this trillion dollar
budget trickle down to see how
it impacts someone's lives.
Local government is where
that fund money eventually
comes into your
programs and projects.
And so the Bloomberg
network, there
are a couple of different
networks that they run.
There's the innovation teams.
They all, I mean, within the
first couple of months of me
joining the I team, we
were visiting Los Angeles
to meet with the other I
teams, and specifically
with Los Angeles's I team
because they were working
on the same issue as we
were going to be working on,
which was the police
recruiting and hiring.
They also run something
called the City Data
Alliance, which is
a cohort right now
of about 20 or 25 cities.
We get technical assistance
around a particular track.
There's executive leadership
training for using data.
So that's another network.
I'm part of, it's called
the Civic Analytics Network,
which is a network of chief
data officers from cities
around the country.
That's run out of
Harvard Kennedy School
by Professor Stephen Goldsmith.
He was a mayor of Indianapolis.
He was a deputy
mayor of New York.
So yeah, like I
said, there's tons.
And through that network, I'll
call up the chief data officer
from Pittsburgh
or Boston and ask
how they're tackling this
problem or what piece of data
stack they're using to
solve different things.
So that's one of the best
parts of the city government
is just being able
to cold call people
from other sides of the
country and figure out
how they solve something.
Thank you so much, Justin.
I tried to capture some of
those links and share them.
But maybe after, I
can email you for some
to share with the
recording, too.
Sure.
Because I saw a
lot of people who
are sharing different open
data portals in their cities,
too, which I can collect
those all together as well.
Yeah.
I know you have a
2 and 1/2 year old
who's trying to take
a nap pretty soon, so.
No, that's the problem.
He's not trying to take a nap.
That's the problem.
He's trying not to.
I might like to go take
a nap right now, but.
Yeah, same.
I just wanted to
check if anybody
is on that had a question you
wanted to ask so we didn't get
to you, I'll give
another opportunity
to raise your hand here.
I think a few people that
asked earlier had to drop, but.
Let's see-- double check.
One hand, there it is.
Hi, Barry.
Hi, everyone.
Mine is not a question.
This is my first
time of joining.
Thanks for joining.
Yes, I'm joining from
Africa, the Gambia.
So I am very, very much
inspired by the speakers.
So I look forward to
joining next week.
Thank you so much.
Awesome, thank you
for joining, yes.
Love to see you next week and
have you join in the LinkedIn
group, too.
And if you have any questions,
feel free to reach out to me,
too.
Thank you all so
much for joining.
Thank you, Justin, for sharing
your insights and experience.
I really, really appreciate it.
This has been a great, lively
discussion for the first one
back of the year.
Cool, thanks for
the invite, Rachel.
This is great.
Thanks for all the
questions everybody.